marcher en ville ou à la campagne c'est
souvent du bonheur un moment
d'insouciance mais quand un piéton et un
conducteur se croisent il suffit d'un
moment d'inattention d'incompréhension
pour que les choses tournent mal
de tous les accidents mortels
l'impliquant un véhicule au pays une
fois sur 6 la victime est un piéton
on l'attribue à différentes choses le
vieillissement de la population parce
que les piétons âgés décèdent plus à
cause de leur âge mais aussi une
augmentation de la masse et de la taille
des véhicules
le parc automobile a changé c'est vrai
en 30 ans le nombre de vies US
camionnette et mini-fourgonnette
attriplé sur les routes au Québec trois
fois sur quatre c'est ce qu'on achète
pour nos déplacements personnels
face à ces véhicules plus lourds le
piéton ne fait plus le poids
80 kg comptent environ 1800 kg pour un
véus
[Musique]
ces véhicules sont aussi souvent plus
hauts en cas d'impact les organes vitaux
et la teinte et Coop les chances que le
piéton s'en sort undemne sont plus
minces au Québec on n'a pas encore
beaucoup regardé les relations mais aux
États-Unis c'est clair que ça a
contribué à des blessures plus graves
chez les piétons
l'Institut d'assurance pour la sécurité
routière aux États-Unis a publié au
printemps 2022 des résultats d'analyses
d'accidents qui allaient dans sens
véhicules sont plus souvent impliqués
dans les accidents mortels de piéton que
dans les accidents moins graves
et des camionnettes frappent un piéton
ils sont plus susceptibles de le tuer
selon l'institut que ce soit aux
intersections lors de virages ou le long
des grandes routes les chances que ces
imposants véhicules soient impliqués
dans un accident mortel de piétons sont
démesurément plus élevés comparativement
en voiture
on soupçonne que c'est la visibilité qui
est en cause c'est peut-être plus
difficile de percevoir des piétons dans
certains de ces gros véhicules
au centre de formation du transport
routier à Mirabel Yannick paiement nous
en fait la démonstration
quand tu réussis à le voir vraiment au
complet tu peux aller un peu de ce côté
là
zone qui disparaît de ma vue derrière le
pilier gauche du pare-brise de l'autre
côté
on a presque deux mètres entre les deux
comptes de zone morte qui est quand même
assez imposante ce qui veut dire que
cette zone là quand est les
problématiques quand on tourne quand on
tourne et cette zone là va tout le temps
se déplacer avec le véhicule avec
l'augmentation de la masse des véhicules
on a vu s'élargir au fil du temps les
piliers de chaque côté du pare-brise
c'était pour mieux protéger les
occupants en cas de tonneaux et y
intégrer des coussins gonflables mais
cela a créé un problème de visibilité
il vient de te déplacer devant moi s'il
te plaît parfait est-ce que tu la vois
encore je le vois encore mais vraiment
partiellement
et si je veux la déplacer là pour
vraiment que tu la perte de vue je
pourrais la placer ici
il a complètement perdu de vue que du
tout
les capots plus longs et plus hautes ce
type de véhicule peuvent dissimuler un
enfant presque entièrement
Jeanne devrait reculer d'environ 6
mètres avant que je ne la voie de la
tête aux pieds
[Musique]
même chose pour les boîtiers des miroirs
leur plus grande taille peut en partie
masquer un enfant qui se trouve derrière
mais le miroir peut nous amener la
mauvaise perception
par rapport à l'image qu'on a à
l'intérieur parce que vu qu'on voit une
réflexion on a tendance à oublier que
derrière le miroir il se crée un angle
mort puis on va complètement oublier le
cet aspect là le profil des angles morts
autour de ce type de véhicule est
immense des piétons pour aisément y
disparaître en toute ou en partie
beaucoup de gens se jettent ce type de
véhicule là mais ça connaître toute la
portée les angles morts lors d'un
véhicule comme ça des angles morts qui
crient des situations à risque
particulièrement durant les virages
on s'apprête à le voir ici en simulateur
l'équipe de virage simulation à Ville
Saint-Laurent a élaboré un scénario type
d'un virage à gauche en milieu urbain
alors ici je m'approche de mon exercice
j'ai préparé mon virage à gauche je
ralentis et vous allez voir que la
petite fillette s'il va venir se cacher
dans mon angle mort
comme le piétons et la voiture se
déplace à la même vitesse le piéton
disparaît un long moment derrière le
pilier du pare-brise
à l'angle mort le fait que la tension du
conducteur est dirigée vers les
véhicules qui viennent en sens inverse
un piéton est donc parfois victime de
l'attention partagée de conducteurs
c'est d'ailleurs pour assister les
conducteurs qu'on introduit de plus en
plus de systèmes d'aide à la conduite
Transport Canada en attesté à Blainville
le système détecte le piéton et frein
automatiquement pour éviter l'impact
aux États-Unis l'Institut d'assurance
pour la sécurité routière a mener le
même genre de test
on a vu que les systèmes fonctionnent
efficacement tout en ayant des lacunes
leurs performance varie beaucoup de
constructeurs à l'autre et d'une vitesse
à l'autre
les chercheurs américains les ont aussi
testé la nuit
quand il fait jour ces systèmes
permettent de réduire de 32% les
accidents impliquant des piétons mais ce
n'est pas le cas quand la nuit
s'installe c'est préoccupant car c'est
durant cette période que l'on enregistre
le plus de décès chez les piétons
à bord de certains véhicules récents des
caméras projettent sur un écran une
vision à 360° autour du véhicule
des caméras qui pourraient peut-être un
jour remplacer des rétroviseurs
la société transport de Montréal en a
fait l'essai sur deux autobus durant un
an
en enlevant les miroirs on a fait
disparaître l'angle mort derrière le
boîtier des caméras ont pris une relais
l'image est projetée dans un écran
accroché au pilier du pare-brise
[Musique]
si on compare l'image de la caméra au
rétroviseur traditionnel on voit que
l'image de la caméra est plus nette quel
que soit la météo ou même la nuit quand
un piéton est à proximité
on va le voir plus clair le soir surtout
de soir et en température normale comme
tempête de neige et puis on le voit plus
clair on est capable de le distinguer
plus facilement on est capable de voir
plus les détails ou si la couleur de ses
vêtements toutes les choses qu'on est
capable de voir avec un miroir
toutes ces innovations pourront-elles
malgré tout minimiser les risques
associés à la prolifération le plus gros
véhicule sur la route les SUV vous savez
c'est très populaire parce que c'est
très sécuritaire pour les gens à
l'intérieur du véhicule c'est les gens à
l'extérieur des véhicules qui sont moins
en sécurité parce que les gens à
l'intérieur le sont plus et c'est
préoccupants dans la mesure où on n'a
pas beaucoup porté attention à ce qui
était à l'extérieur des véhicules
et c'est en partie la réflexion à
laquelle sont confrontés les
législateurs comme les constructeurs
d'automobiles à savoir que la sécurité
des uns ne peut pas se faire au
détriment des autres les plus
vulnérables